this idea of leadership being subtle
it's not as satisfying as people want it
to to be and they want this thing where
it's loud and spotlights on you and you
jump in and you mean where your ego gets
completely yeah man and you want to look
around and and and you're welcome the
subtlety of that in all the examples you
go through it's it's everywhere in
leadership is the subtlety of it and
that really comes from part of it comes
from experience but it's also
recognizing what are other people going
through before you make a decision this
reminds me of something we talked about
early on this podcast this podcast was
you know I was saying listen if you're
doing it right you're winning a battle
and the other person doesn't even know
that there was a battle going on right
you want it and and then you have to you
have to control your ego enough that you
don't say look I just want you to even
know it because then you just threw it
out the window
same thing here if you're really doing
leadership well the team barely even
knows that you're leading them they can
barely even feel it like they and it's
like this unseen forces there they kind
of know but they almost feel it's their
own force and they're making things
happen that they think are their own
things and all you're doing is you
you're you're being so subtle that they
barely even know that they're being led
and that is optimal now you do have to
be careful because people have to people
have to undo that so much that they
don't recognize you as the leader
because now there's gonna be times when
they look to turn to someone and they
don't turn to you right which can be a
problem so we have to be a little bit
careful but that is so rare that you
could actually pull that off and the
reason it's rare to pull that off is
because teams and organizations and
people trying to get things done require
leadership yeah they require times when
the leaders known and so those times are
enough few and far between if it's seven
like we talked about on the last pot
guys if it's seven times in every three
years this is there anyone that's
walking around like well you know I
doubt Jacko's you using him seem like he
knows what's going on anymore like
there's no one walking
saying that but the leadership is subtle
it's like mmm we seem to be man we're
doing good what's going on here this
this is working out nice wow this is
cool
no one's going like hey well I'm ready
to just I'm doing all this myself
yeah and that's the way you want it to
be you want to win without them knowing
you're fighting and you want to lead
without them barely even know knowing
that you're leading and the biggest
hardest part of that to do in both those
cases is put your ego and check enough
that you can that you can win without
gloating and that you can lead without
credit that's what you want I'm gonna
continue on here when someone else
wouldn't step up quickly it was usually
because no one else had noticed that
there was a leadership vacuum they
wouldn't notice because they were not
detached their minds were absorbed in
the situation since I practiced being
detached I wasn't lost in the details of
what was going on I was mentally in a
different place looking at the scenario
unfold from a virtual distance which
allowed me to see problems more quickly
that still doesn't mean I would jump
right in by letting a little more time
pass by letting that leadership void
linger just a little bit longer everyone
else would begin to notice it they would
recognize there was a problem since that
time past and now everyone else knew
there was a problem when I gave orders
on how to solve it people would listen
and they would execute another reason to
pause before jumping into a leadership
vacuum as soon as you see it is to make
sure that no one else is jumping in
there if two people step in to fill a
leadership void at the same time they
usually bump into each other when they
get there and then while the problem is
growing they have to take precious time
to sort out which person is actually
gonna lead and which one is gonna stand
down
and if egos clashed at that moment we're
gonna have a bigger problem
I would rather avoid that if someone
else is going to step in with a plan
it's fine with me when I see the void I
pause look around assess if anyone else
is going to step up and lead while I do
this
problem grows pretty much very soon
everyone notices the problem I see that
and then step up and make a call a call
that everyone know needs to be made now
what this is a real obvious answer but
it's not so obvious when you're in the
heat of the moment something's going on
and I make a call an echo makes a call
at the same time what do I do
let me leave immediately defer alright
hey cool I got you I mean as long I
assess your plan and a half a second and
go good enough all right cool I got you
your right go yeah you gotta be like
pretty aggressive with that letting them
lead cuz you know like you know like
you're going to the supermarket right
and then you're walking in and you're
about to hit the entrance door boom and
someone else is coming with you know
they're hitting the ancient store at the
exact same time seams ain't part of your
team our unknown unknown or whatever no
no unknown yeah I guess unknown but
whatever yeah unknown this is where it
would happen the most with a stranger
then you're like oh you're polite guy
right let him go but they're just as
polite as you so they're like no no you
go no no you go and then you guys both
decide okay let's not play this game
I'll go but you both decided at the same
time so you guys both going now you're
at state step one again you seem sane so
what I would do okay I'm not saying
either one good comment today but but
understand it kind of seems like the
same thing different is this a different
level it is it is the same thing where
both people are going on I'm gonna make
a call and and that is why yes you're
right that's why even when I did this
for second role play I was like you're
right you got it go like I'm gonna make
it that clear yeah yeah I feel that way
too like if someone's like like nope you
go like straight up nope you go if they
have like this weird aggressive sort of
way I'm being I will be way more
compelled to go
so you're saying or if it's like a lot
of times it's like with a friend who
you're just not quite as close with them
so there's kind of just you're still
trying to be polite I'll just push them
in we might want to we might want to do
a podcast on that like just that right
just supermarket entries
maybe